قال رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع
سوداني ان الحكومه العراقيه بصدد تحديد
موعد بدء عمل لجنه ثنائيه لوضع ترتيبات
انهاء وجود قوات التحالف الدولي في العراق
بصوره نهائيه واضاف السوداني ان الحكومه
العراقيه تؤكد موقفها الثابت في انهاء
الوجود التحالف الدولي بعد ان انتهت
مبررات وجوده حسب تعبيره
معنا من بغداد مراسل الجزيره عامر لافي
عامر اذا رئيس الوزراء العراقي يتحدث عن
البدء بوضع ترتيبات مثل ما قال انهاء وجود
قوات التحالف الدولي في العراق
وبصوره نهائيه ماذا في
التفاصيل نعم وسيله يعني يمكننا القول بان
هذا المطلب هو مطلب قديم متجدد فرض اعاده
الحديث عنه من قبل رئيس الوزراء والذي
بالمناسبه منذ قدومه الى السلطه وهو يتحدث
عن ضروره اخراج التحالف الدولي من العراق
على الاعتبار ان مبررات وجوده قد انتهت
لكن كما ذكرنا التطورات الاخيره وربما ما
جاء بالامس عندما قصف التحالف الدولي احد
مقرات الحشد الشعبي في شرق العاصمه بغداد
وهو ما ادى الى مقتل احد قاده الحشد
ومرافقه هذا طبعا تلاه العديد من
المطالبات من ممثلين عن فصائل المقاومه
العراقيه من ومن الحشد الشعبي ومن
الممثلين عن الاحزاب السياسيه العراقيه
بضروره اخراج التحالف من العراق على
اعتبار انه كما ذكرنا لم يعد هناك مبرر
لوجوده اليوم كانت المناسبه هي الذكرى
الرابعه لتابين قاسم سليماني الذي اتلته
الولايات المتحده هنا في بغداد وبالتالي
كان هناك نقطتين رئيسيتين تناولهما رئيس
الوزراء عندما تحدث عن ضروره اخراج
التحالف وبان هذه الخطوه لن تتراجع عنها
الحكومه العراقيه وانها لن تتراجع عن كل
ما يمكنه استكمال سياده العراق على حد
وصفه النقطتان الرئيسيتان هو تذكيره بما
جرى هنا قبل اربع سنوات عندما قال بان ما
قامت به الولايات المتحده كانت جريمه
نكراء على حد وصفه عندما قامت باغتيال
سليماني هنا في العراق وان هذا خرق لكل
المواثيق الدوليه التي تحدد العلاقه بين
الدول وسياده الدول وما قامت به امر غير
مقبول الامر الاخر والنقطه الثانيه ما حدث
بالامس
تناوله الشياع محمد شياع السوداني وقال
بان ما جرى غير مقبول على اعتبار ان الحشد
الشعبي هو جزء لا يتجزا من القوات
العسكريه العراقيه وانه اي خرق او اي
تجاوز يحدث في الدوله العراقيه فان الدوله
العراقيه ورئاسه الوزراء هي المخول الوحيد
في التعامل مع اي تجاوز وبالتالي لا يمكن
لاي جهه اخرى خارج العراق ان تقوم بالتدخل
في الشؤون العراقيه في هذا الاطار وبان ما
جرى غير مقبول وعليه قال وتحدث عن ضروره
اخراج التحالف الدولي من العراق شرا جزيلا
لك عامر لافي مراسلنا من
بغداد